I'm Glenn Loury Merton P Stoltz
professor of the Social Sciences and
professor of economics at Brown
University
I don't know that it can teach us all
that much I mean I thought it was
overblown as being implemented of race
relations or profiling or anything of
that sort I didn't read it as you know
insightful or really useful in that
regard though I do think how we reacted
to the incident you know what it became
drawing the president in and so someone
perhaps would tell us something about
and this was my argument in the piece
how we process racial issues how we talk
and don't talk about them maybe how we
are quick to repair to some conventional
and Pat storyline about them you know
the country had a problem has had a
problem is trying to overcome it some
people are slower at that than others
there's a racist behind every Bush let's
not tolerate the racist this kind of
talk and I just thought the gates
incident and again the president's
handling of it showed the thinness of
that narrative how that line was
probably not any longer if ever it was
adequate to capture the you know the
reality of our racial condition if you
will
want to pretend to omniscience here but
I'd say I'd say there there are some
asked several aspects of it that I would
point out one is the continuing fact of
a developmental lag or gap between the
african-american population taken as a
whole not of course including every
person on the one hand and the rest of
the much of the rest of the country on
the other blacks are not the only group
of people who manifest certain of the
kinds of problems that I would talk
about here and that are reflected in
policing in prisons problems of poor
education and intermittent employment
and you know limited full human
development problems of fragile and
fractured communities and families of
large numbers of under socialized and
underdeveloped young people who end up
getting into trouble of you know and I
could go on and you see the the line
that this would draw it would say that
the African American population
taken as a whole lags behind on the
average along many of these dimensions
this is a stubborn reality and it has
consequences and it can't be easily
reconciled with a pat account about
racism and discrimination that lets us
sort of relax into saying you know when
we finally get this right when we get
rid of racism when we reach the
post-racial society everything's going
to be okay well no because along the way
here as we've not yet been in this
racial Nirvana facts on the ground have
been created blighted lives have played
themselves out and human difficulties
have developed and these are stark
they're staring us in the face
they're the subtext for a lot of our
politics they're that they're the story
behind the story
so when gates a Harvard professor god
bless him I certainly intend him no ill
will
but when he trots out this story about a
racist rogue police officer and when he
begins to embrace this rhetoric of
racial profiling frankly and when the
president buys into this and unlike what
the wisdom that he typically exhibits
President Obama in conducting public
affairs makes a huge mistake by buying
into this it is a distraction from the
real story the real story two and a
quarter million Americans half of whom
are black under lock and key on a given
day the real story stop in frisk as the
police technique de jour in City after
City around this country where the
rubber hits the road in terms of
profiling where people are getting sent
off to Rikers Island because they had a
joint in their pocket and so forth and
so on where the real story is kids
learning how to be men from other kids
who've been locked up for five years and
then get out because they all get out go
back to the same neighborhoods and strut
their new bodies and their tattoos and
they're hardened attitudes as a part of
the social consoling that ends up
forming the normative structure of these
communities and I'm talking about tens
upon tens upon tens of thousands of them
in and out in and out of this system if
I may say so how dare a Harvard
professor and a President of the United
States cheapen the serious political
conversation that we have to have about
locking up millions of our fellow
citizens by repairing to a pat
all-too-familiar storyline about racism
and profiling in the abstract against
black men in general even on Martha's
Vineyard I'm telling you that that is
not the politics of change that we were
promised during the campaign of 2008
in my mind if we're going to look these
problems of disparity between racial
groups in the United States disparity of
human development and acquired capacity
for functioning look these problems
directly on then the solutions that
suggest themselves to me are building a
system of social supports of mutual
support that includes everyone and that
therefore eases the the difficult
situation of people who are especially
disadvantaged which people will be
disproportionately present in in the
african-american population in a
disadvantaged racial minority population
so we need you know to fix the schools
we actually I think need to spend a lot
more than we do spend on educating our
young people
our sentences are way too long okay I
would I mean let's just start with
something very specific and very
concrete you can put a person in jail
for five years for ten years or twenty
years for the same crime we're deciding
on ten years to twenty years when five
years would be enough okay the deterrent
value the additional amount of leverage
that you get over a criminal to keep
them from breaking the law in the first
place
associated with making the sentences
longer is de minimis it's essentially
nothing the research shows this three
strikes and you in your outlaws the laws
that say if you do a crime three times
you can be sentenced to 25 years for
life the laws that have got the jails of
California overflowing are they're
madness as policy they're they're
expressive political symbols capturing
the anger of people at social
dysfunction and allowing politicians to
show that they're responsive to that
anger
had some problems with the law including
being arrested for possession of a
controlled substance now I've just
advocated decriminalized into possession
of controlled substances that sounds a
bit self-serving and perhaps it is
certainly having the personal experience
of being you know locked up not for a
long time I was locked up overnight
being accused of a serious crime I was
accused of assaulting someone the
charges were later dropped in the
context of a dispute Laden personal
relationship the charges were later
dropped for what it's worth I was not
guilty of the charge but I was accused
of assaulting somebody and therefore
confronting real criminal liability at
least potentially didn't work out that
way but there I was in that spotlight
the stigma you know when you're signaled
out as someone who has done something
wrong that stays with you even if you
haven't done the thing that people think
you might have done and so forth and so
on
I suppose that also has affected me I'd
also say the way that I came up in
Chicago not a poor family not a you know
sort of stereotypical sort of ghetto
upbringing if you will but nevertheless
one with some rough edges and one where
you know there were people with one foot
to either side of the law who were you
know regular presences in my young world
as a boy and a young man growing up in
Chicago my uncle would take me to the
state pen to visit friends of his who
were incarcerated he wanted me to have
the experience of going there there but
for the grace of God go I he would say
to me about these people who were in the
prison I think that kind of thing surely
has had some effect on me also
I think I decriminalize I think I would
heavily regulate in control I think I if
you're asking me and you know my mouth
is no prayer book but my view is I'd
view addiction to these substances as a
medical problem and I would treat it
accordingly what little I know about the
history of drug control policy in the
United States leads me thinking that a
hugely important moment came when the
lawyers went out over the doctors on
this matter that is to say when the
medical profession basically surrendered
and perhaps they had no choice in the
matter their autonomy to handle the
difficult problems of addiction to
substances which is a medical problem to
the anti drug Crusaders legal Crusaders
who wanted to make everything against
the law and then throw people in prison
just as we can see in retrospect that
criminalizing the consumption of alcohol
proved not to be the solution to the
very real problem of drunkenness so -
what I want to say is the very real
problem of the human susceptibility to
addiction isn't best dealt with by
building prisons and throwing people
into jails
I think the world tears think I'm most
terrified of now that may seem to be
coming out of Veidt on the left field or
the stratosphere I'm not sure where that
comes from cuz we've been talking about
race and domestic American policy and
drugs and whatnot and I'm not a foreign
policy expert by any means I'm not I'm
not and yet you know Iraq Afghanistan
not just that but the whole kind of
taking over of our defense and security
establishment by this mentality this
kind of Orwellian war against the
shape-shifting and faceless and almost
undefinable enemy the war that never
ends I mean when is it going to be over
the war that someone even dare not say
you know we're not fighting it anymore I
mean you know it's kind of I'm not only
talking about the threats to our civil
liberties from surveillance I'm not only
talking about the damage to our national
reputation from the actions that we've
taken with with enemy combatants and
others detaining these people kidnapping
these people torturing these people I'm
not only talking about that I'm talking
about getting used to being at war the
country's been at war for ten years for
a decade we're settling into being at
war that's terrifying in the extreme to
me we we've defined this problem like we
were little Israel sitting there
surrounded by great Arab armies in the
in the myth in the storyline like like
like we're we're we've got to engage in
the drone operated assassinations of
potential enemies we've got to accept
this standard operating procedure the
collateral damage and which whole
families are wiped out sometimes by
accident sometimes because they were in
the wrong place at the wrong time and
the best we had to say for it is that it
wasn't our intention to kill them we've
got this volunteer army where
nine-tenths of the population sits back
on our haunches hoping that the price of
gasoline doesn't go to high
well we've got a professionalized
fighting class and what do you think
those people are going to do when we're
finished with them in Afghanistan in
Iraq they're coming home they're coming
home with all of the scars of battle
with all of the habituated attitudes of
violence with with with everything
that's serving in a theater of combat
sometimes two and three times over will
affect in the life of a human being
where we're biting off a huge huge huge
headache here and the fact that we don't
talk about it
then we don't have a politics in which
this question of warring peace can even
get on to the table so that we can open
up our or well our 1984 or Animal Farm
or whatever and read the political text
that would be that's being spouted to us
on the television right off of the page
the fact that we don't have a politics
robust enough to actually debate whether
or not we want to be a country
permanently at war that's what keeps me
from sleeping at night
I'm left okay and sometimes radically
and sometimes I even shock myself with
the degree of radicalness in my own you
know that's that I'm allowing to come
out in my old age
on the other hand there's some of my you
know I got the reputation of being a
conservative because I was one of these
personal responsibility guys you know
before Bill Cosby made it popular
talking about how black people need to
pull up our socks how you need to take
better care of our children and you know
get our acts together and and how that
was an internal difficulty that we
needed to actually address within
ourselves and I even flirted a little
bit with you know sort of black
nationalism I mean I had more than a
kind word to say about the Minister
Louis Farrakhan I once wrote a piece
about the Million Man March 1995 Million
Man March Washington DC Louis Farrakhan
which is remembered I think nowadays
mostly because Farrakhan gave a very odd
and rambling and in places incoherent
and in other places kind of weird speech
it went on for 90 minutes or something
like that at this Million Man March but
the thing that I remember was 1 million
more or less african-american men
assembled in one place
emphasizing communal uplift
responsibility and you know a positive
agenda and I I was very much taken by
that and I guess that's still lingers in
me to some degree I also have this anti
political correctness thing that's a
part of my persona I mean I just haven't
drunk anybody's kool-aid you know what I
mean I mean I just can't go with them
with the flow I mean when Chris Matthews
thinks Obama is great
that's when I start saying ok let me
take another look at this Obama you know
what I mean because this is you know so
I just can't and therefore I may be hard
to pigeonhole because I'm gonna be on
you know the contrary inside or whatever
the thing might be I think the war on
terror is horrible I hated what the Bush
administration was doing on the other
hand I didn't think that we should
criminalize those policy differences by
going after these people after the fact
and I thought that all that man way
and stuff about how Eric Holder honor
you know let's prosecute him and let's
indict Bush and Cheney and how I thought
it was crazy and irresponsible I'm you
know I'm likely to say something like
that
the one thing that I want to say is that
the progressive forces in our country
including those in the press I don't
think do the cause any good by not
reporting with brutal critical candor
and scrutiny on this administration
every bit as much as they would do on
any other administration now I hope that
in the fullness of time we're only nine
months into this eight months into this
I will be proving wrong about this but I
have detected from time to time a
reticence and a kind of as if the
campaign was still going on and we all
kind of know that people who are
covering campaigns and the press develop
allegiances and that colors the way in
which they do their reporting I don't
think that's disputable I think there's
plenty of evidence to that effect on all
sides but the campaign has long since
over and we really need our hard-hitting
critical critical press I mean I see
elements of it but I don't see it to its
full extent I'm talking about for
example on these questions of war and
peace I don't take it as a given at all
that we need to be doubling down in
Afghanistan I don't take that as a given
at all that's the direction in which the
president is going
I want hard-hitting critical assessment
of that from the liberal and progressive
media not merely he's our guy we got to
protect him kind of reaction that is
somehow what I feel like I'm getting
from my little small part in my little
corner of the the public policy world
and you know I write about race and
affirmative action and racial
discrimination and you know domestic
policy and prisons and all this kind of
thing
I'm sure determined to do that I'm
determined as I was trying to do in
reaction to this and we Lewis gates
affair to call the president out when I
think he's making mistakes and when I
think he's got it when he's got it wrong
and to do that as a part of my you know
responsibility as a you know public
intellectual and so forth and so on so
for what that may be worth I'll say that
that's right my pastor this little
church that I used to go to when I was a
better Christian than I am now who and
his wife had devoted their physicians
harvard-trained physician has devoted
his entire life to building a church in
a community in Boston and this helped
thousands and thousands of people and
it's as pious and is serious and as
humane a human being as you can you
might imagine Reverend ray Hammond I'm
glad to be able to put him at the top of
my list no I'm not running for anything
in Boston I don't need his endorsement
but he certainly he's certainly a good
man another guy I think of who I admire
tremendously is Ernesto Cortez who's a
well-known community organizer the
industrial areas foundation he works out
of Austin Texas but he's organizing
throughout the southwest and I'm known
in between 25 years and I tell you that
these community organizers of some of
these places you know in New Orleans and
in Houston and San Antonio and LA
various cities around the southwest I've
had a chance to interact with him down
in the Rio Grande Valley you know with
the a Mexican immigrant population and
stuff like that organizing I've been to
you know holiday ends at the airport and
500 people wearing the tank same t-shirt
had been jumping up and down inside of
auditorium talking about they were gonna
get a community college education so
they can run one of these MRI machines
at the hospital or something like that
they were talking about we want $25 an
hour jobs not minimum-wage jobs and
we're prepared to you know you know I
just see not to go on too long about it
but here's a guy who is spending his
life he's a thoughtful he's an
intellectual this is Ernesto Cortez the
organizer he's an intellectual but he's
also a practical politician and when I
say that I don't mean that he's running
for office but I mean he's dealing with
the kind of small P politics getting
people together getting them talking to
each other getting them to feel that
they have the capacity to change their
lives getting them organized have
tremendous respect for that work
I see a political issue here the
President of the United States Barack
Hussein Obama elected comfortably in his
first year with a very ambitious agenda
inheriting a economic crisis passing
massive fiscal legislation in this
stimulus package which has huge
implications down the road budget area
tax wise and so forth and so on and
having at the top of his agenda
reforming health care needs to win this
one right he wins this one he gets this
done he is a long way toward a
successful first term he's a long way
toward you know minimizing whatever
setbacks the Democrats might have in the
2010 mid-year elections midterm
elections and you know he's up there
with LBJ and FDR in terms of solidifying
the 20th 21st century American welfare
state this is major health care is major
so the politics of this as you know the
right wing understands very very well is
is tremendously profound so I see I see
the policy issues I see the politics but
I also see the moral issue because this
really is about who we are as a people
here and this health care debate now you
know everybody knows the history
Clinton's tried they failed early in
their administration and they suffered
serious setbacks in the 94 elections and
the rest is history
Obama is teetering here he tries he
fails then we've got two failures right
to try to do this and the fact that we
are the only advanced industrial
democracy where people can get sick and
languish because they can't afford care
or where people are blocked in access to
this system because they don't have
access to insurance which is only
available through certain narrow portals
and under certain very restricted
conditions the fact that we're the only
society that hasn't embraced this idea
that no one should go without access to
these services regardless of their
of their financial condition and no one
should be saddled with a lifetime of
debt because they have the misfortune of
falling ill that's a major moral issue
so I see it as a moment of big moral
challenge for the country
I want the president to succeed here and
I want the country to move in this
direction there's a lot to pick over and
argue about on the policy front I get
the public option because it's the
stalking horse I know I'm not supposed
to say this I know that this is not the
line
it's the camels nose under the tent for
what I think is the correct solution to
this problem which is the so called
single-payer system which is Medicare
for all which is the government stands
behind collects the taxes to pay for
regulates the provision of but stands
behind the provision of these services
to everybody that's not to stop somebody
who has a lot of money from buying
something extra that's to say here's the
government and we're providing this to
everybody now people have said that they
can't get that done politically here in
the United States and I see that very
clearly the vitriolic and hysterical
attacks against the president's efforts
to reform health care labeling whim
socialism talking of them in terms of
you know fascist and government you know
profound government intrusion into the
lives of people when in fact what it is
is what every other advanced wealthy
democratic industrialized country has
done and nothing more shows me that to
come straight out for the single-payer
system would probably meet with
political failure therefore we have had
to invent this end run around the
political realities and as I understand
the public option and I know there'd be
a lot of debate about this that's the
main role of it
they say compete with insurance
companies I think what it actually means
is compel or coerce or you know drive
insurance companies into a mode of
behavior we're not going to get rid of
the insurance middleman here with a
single-payer system but we're going to
create a public presence in the
insurance industry powerful enough to
drive the direction of the industry and
the way that we together with regulation
wanted to go and so therein lies the big
policy the big policy debate what I
think about that is I wish that we had
the capacity to go directly at the
single-payer system I think what we're
doing is messy so mess
that the president can't explain it and
he's pretty good you know he's pretty
good at explaining stuff and people
still don't really get what's going on
because it's messy there's a lot of
there's a lot of demagogic rhetoric and
not only on the right you know there's a
lot of this some of this writing about
the insurance company said I hear coming
for example from the Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi I wish would be
reconsidered
I say this is a guy who I think of
myself as on the left but you know I
think that if you have a system where
you say you're selling insurance to
people it's very natural that the
companies selling the assurance are
gonna try to vet claims and minimize the
amount of payments that they have to
make if you have a system that says
everybody who needs health care gets it
and we're going to make sure that it
gets paid for by raising their taxes and
providing the requirements on
individuals where they have the ability
to pay such as we determine as
appropriate then the insurance issue
doesn't come up so you know what am I
trying to say about the insurance
companies I think the talk about
insurance company profit and insurance
company venality as the source of this
problem is a byproduct of our
unwillingness to confront head-on the
the sort of deeper moral issue which is
that we should provide the services in
terms of health care to the people who
need them more or less regardless of
their ability to pay and it's it's it's
divisive its divisive political rhetoric